[Music]  find out what your council has done for  you we're making Baber a better place  for everyone we're investing millions in  our swimming pools building more  affordable homes and making sure our  streets are clean tidy and safe this is  all while having one of the lowest  council taxes in the country the first  time in 30 years we are building council  houses again we've brought empty  properties back into use created  accessible homes and tackled  homelessness community groups in Suffolk  do some truly amazing work they helped  thousands of people we have secured  funding to make that possible this is  helping to make baver a stronger  community making sure we build the right  homes in the right places is one of our  most important jobs and we are also  helping local communities with their own  plans  we are Baber District Council we are  your council find out what we have done  for you